plus on commence donc par parler de
cette opération turc en syrie la france
a réuni un conseil de défense
elle explique qu'il est absolument
scandaleux d'avoir abandonné ainsi les
kurdes à la vindicte des turcs mais le
problème c'est qu'on peut rien faire de
concret et on se dit stéphane marchand
qu'il ya qu un seul mot qui convient ses
impuissances oui oui enfin vous savez
les kurdes depuis 1920 et peut-être même
avance en sont les victimes des jeux
entre les grandes puissances
les kurdes sont eux-mêmes
extraordinairement divisés entre eux et
par conséquent à chaque fois que à
chaque fois que l'on médiatise un crime
commis contre les kurdes et bien entre
les kurdes
il ya des divisions qui sont commises et
des crimes qui sont commis aussi entre
les kurdes je rappelle ça pour montrer
que la situation est plus complexe qu'il
qu'il n'y paraît quant aux turcs leur
offensive est d'une très grande
brutalité en étant d'une très grande
logique et d'une très grande crédibilité
à chaque fois que la menace existe de
voir se constituer une zone tampon aux
frontières de la turquie contrôlé par
les kurdes
eh bien les clés les turcs attaque c'est
systématique ça ne changera probablement
pas à court terme et la france est
incapable est incapable seul de faire
quelque chose sauf peut-être en frappant
la turquie au portefeuille de manière
sérieuse et en organisant en europe
quelque chose de fort pour bloquer par
exemple les exportations les
investissements turcs mais comme en ce
moment la france est dans une position
en europe
relativement délicate après la sphère du
rejet de sa commissaire est bien le
moment n'est pas vraiment très bien
choisi nicolas lokossa on pourrait
riposter entre guillemets sur un
registre économique se serait efficace
la france a déjà annoncé qu'elle
suspendait ses exportations d'armes en
turquie mais comme si à peu près 0 ça va
pas très loin mais ça va pas très loin
la france n'a pas les moyens on le voit
même l'europe n'a pas les moyens
d'intervenir ou de faire quoi que ce
soit je fais plus confiance au sénat
américain
le sénateur lindsey graham qui est très
active sur ce point là et je
je pense qu'ils vont prendre des mesures
de rétorsion économique financière à
l'égard la turquie donc là j'ai plus
confiance dans ce sens là que du point
de vue de la france qui n'a pas les
moyens de faire quoi que ce soit les
turcs sont en position de force
richard bride on rappellera que il ya
plusieurs millions de migrants qui sont
derrière la frontière turque erdogan
disant aux européens attention vous
n'êtes pas gentils avec nous j'ouvre mes
frontières il arrive chez vous mais
clairement on a sur ce sujet ce point
qui est une faiblesse des européens
d'une manière générale puisque
aujourd'hui comme vous le dites une
partie de la politique vis-à-vis des
réfugiés a été déléguée à la turquie que
par ailleurs la turquie fait aussi objet
dead pour la france puisque sur son
territoire quand elle voit des
jihadistes français il y a avec la
france un principe qui est celui de
d'extradition la haute thur qui rend
donc des services aujourd'hui bien sûr
joue de cette capacité de nuisance dans
dans les relations
ça m'inspire deux choses très rapidement
d'abord vous rappeler en mars 2018 le
président macron avait reçu à l'elysée à
des responsables de kurdes de syrie
parce que déjà à l'époque la turquie
menaçait d'aller faire la guerre contre
contre les kurdes et déjà à l'époque on
parlait de l'impuissance française
la deuxième chose que ça m'inspire c'est
que aujourd'hui on s'inquiète beaucoup
et à juste raison que cette offensive va
probablement libéré des personnes qui
sont aujourd'hui emprisonnés parmi
lesquels se trouvent probablement est
dédié à liszt et pourquoi pas des
cellules un peu dormantes de dice
mais ce débat on l'a pas accepté on l'a
pas posé en france vous les tons que ce
soit des personnes qui soient
emprisonnés et jugés sur place vous
voulez ton qu'à un moment donné il y ait
des personnes qui reviennent qu'ils
soient jugés en france et qui soit à la
fois condamné bien évidemment et qu'ils
soient emprisonnés dans des prisons
digne de ce nom le kosovo l'a fait le
kosovo l'a fait mais c'est pas un gros
pays en europe les autres ne l'ont pas
fait aujourd'hui on se pose des
questions que finalement il y a déjà
quelques mois voire quelques années on
se on se posait déjà et on en est
effectivement à redire l'impuissance de
la france seule sauf une coalition
occidentale
même pas une coalition simplement des
européens mais occidental qui inclut
bien évidemment les états unis je ne
vois pas comment un moment donné erdogan
arrêtera et je finirai will et les
kurdes sont divisés et c'est aussi un
des jeux du président sur parce que il
ya des partis qui ne sont pas le pkk en
turquie
je pense notamment aux hdp un parti
démocratique qui a des élus des députés
et des maires qui depuis 2016 font
l'objet d'une purge et d'une vague
d'arrestations qui aujourd'hui sont dans
les prisons donc tout ça réfléchit
beaucoup la situation lui donne des
éléments les turcs font des affaires
considérable avec le kurdistan irakien
il ya énormément d'investissement turc
dans cette zone par milliards de dollars
et par conséquent il n'y a pas
d'opposition
il ya deux fatalités absolument de
conflit entre les turcs et les kurdes
non on rappellera que les kurdes qui
sont présents dans plusieurs pays n'ont
pas de nation mais ils ont une très
large autonomie en irak dans ce
kurdistan irakien dont vous venez de
parler périco légasse finalement on
découvre les limites l'a22 de
multilatéralisme de la diplomatie face à
des gens qui sont déterminés et brutaux
et bien nous les occidentaux on est
faible si on en découvrait que les
limites ça serait bien nous sommes bien
roland de 1938 trahison et l'acheter
quand ils ont donné leur vie à notre
place contre des ch
on est évidemment tous pour le kurdistan
et pour les curieux à leur promet des
institutions et une nation aujourd'hui
on les abandonne comme il nous est
arrivé dans l'histoire d'abandonner des
populations il ya deux leçons à tirer
alors qu'en 1938 c'est quoi ces les
années que les vacances devenu une icône
en fait on s'écrase mais que ce soit là
et que ce soit la préfecture de police
on s'écrase on est dans un système de
lâcheté institutionnels on a peur de
stigmatiser
on a peur de provoquer on a peur de
faire peur donc on ne fait rien et on se
laisse massacrer
voilà parce que je pense que ce n'est
pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui mais je pense
que entre hasard à tora et ses alliés
dont on aurait pu penser la chose
différemment et ne pas accepter
certaines choses avec de la tolérance
zéro comme cela existe pour le kurdistan
et même chose
il y avait des seuils que la turquie ne
pouvait pas franchir je constate deux
choses
alors on incrimine la france on est
quand même allé au mali pour moins que
ça mais c'est vrai que le mali on avait
des racines et c'est un peu moins loin
on a eu besoin de l'aviation américaine
pour y aller que lis tu en as parlons
pas de cession s'est dévoué pour le
kurdistan madame mitterrand bernard
kouchner
aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus je prends
ce stade seulement que nous payons très
cher la facture
de d'une mesure absolument crétine et
insupportable qui est le rejet de la
réussite de scouts in par monsieur
fabius et monsieur hollande nos alliés
dans ce cas là ce sont eux c'est pas
monsieur trump c'est pas les états unis
qui sont ravis que les que l'europe se
délite et je pense que s'il pouvait
transporter les djihadistes en europe
pour qui un peu plus d'eux confie ce
serait très bien je lui ai besoin mes
mots mais je sens que cet homme a envie
de disloquer l'europe nous avions un
allié en historique c'est la russie
n'est ce pas quand en 1940 et 44 ni de
gauche ni de sorties d'été stalinien et
la russie soviétique et si la réussite
la russie dont bachar el-assad
merris donc allez donc finalement tout
ça pour ça on a dégommé le système de
quelques est une dictature épouvantable
et on est aujourd'hui content que ce
soit les syrien de bachar el-assad
avec l'accord des russes qui viennent
faire notre boulot pour protéger les
kurdes alors que s'écrasent devant la
turquie qui nous menace d'ouvrir ses
frontières
non seulement aux migrants qui sont par
millions mais éventuellement la menace
selon eux ce sont les médias liste donc
on est dans une capitulation totale une
humiliation totale et c'est la honte
pour l'occident et l'europe je vous
donne des le point de vue de nos
internautes vous êtes très majoritaire
c'est pas une surprise a trouvé que la
france est impuissante face à
l'offensive turque contre les codes 84 %
de ceux qui sont en train de nous suivre
et qui voiture twitter s'exprime dans ce
sens s'il nous dit il faut espérer qu'à
turquie et la syrie vont trouver un
accord pour l'instant c'est plutôt
l'affrontement qui semble se préciser
philippe la question qui se pose est
plutôt quel intérêt avons-nous à
soutenir les kurdes
peut-être que
ils contrôlaient les djihadistes qui
sont sinon susceptibles de revenir en
france
et puis nicole j'espère qu'avec ce qui
se passe avec la turquie on va arrêter
les discussions d'entrée dans l'union
européenne
parce que c'est vrai que la turquie en
principe c'est un de nos alliés d'abord
la procédure d'admission dans l'union
européenne et sont pas arrêtés et puis
rappelons le les turcs ils sont membres
de l'otan comme nous est ce qu'ils
peuvent y rester très longtemps c'est
pas sûr en tout cas c'est le point de
vue de bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie
la turquie est membre de l'otan enfin
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une alliance dans
laquelle un des alliés
la turquie prend des décisions qui sont
objectivement contraire à nos intérêts
fondamentaux de sécurité ça pose une
question grave aussi sur le
fonctionnement des alliances et sur les
choix qui ont été faits en matière
méditerranée protéger tant il faut
masquer leurs militaires et stratégiques
par les états unis
donc quand je n'en tire qu'une seule
conclusion il est temps que l'union
européenne comme le présent de la
république le propose depuis maintenant
plus de deux ans soit militairement la
plus indépendante possible ses fans
marchand vous avait-elle correspondant
du figaro aux etats unis c'est vrai que
c'est la mairie qui a qu'a voulu que la
turquie soit soit dans l'otan et qu'elle
y soit toujours il a toujours été
considérée comme très important que la
turquie ne se fonde pas dans un ensemble
islamo turque vers l'est et par
conséquent toutes les tentatives ont été
plutôt de la ramener vers l'ouest soit
en la mettant dans le temps soit en la
mettant dans l'union européenne un
projet de l'est maintenant
ou les deux si c'était possible voilà
maintenant on sent bien que la turquie
est un est un pays extraordinairement
puissance une civilisation qui est
souvent pas suffisamment prise au
sérieux elle a des intérêts elle estime
les défendre et et et voilà et les
intérêts turcs en attaquant au kurdistan
ressemblent pas toutes choses
comparables aux intérêts de la france
qui ne veut pas les djihadistes rentrer
dire ce sont des sons des intérêts de
même nature considéré comme essentiel
vécu comme essentielle pratiquer comme
essentiel à mon avis faut prendre la
turquie plus au sérieux
quelques commentaires d'internautes
babineau qui déplore le manque de prise
de position forte de macron et puis
johnny keragis sur youtube pour nous
dire qu'il faut rappeler que les kurdes
ont combattu des ch
quand nous avions peur d'aller sur le
terrain
pour l'europe parce que là je disais je
suis dit c'est ma phrase tout à l'heure
la france d'accord mais c'est pas la
france
là c'est la première puissance mondiale
qu'est l'union européenne comment se
fait-il qu'en 2019 avait tout ce qu'on
nous a promis tout ce qu'on veut
inventer il n'y ait pas une puissance
militaire européenne de circonstance
pour la peine qu'elle soit permanente
mais qu'on puisse dire madame merkel
quand même bien qu'il ya comme ça que
ces puissances et même les enlever y
serait allé
malgré leur réussite pour aller soutenir
les kurdes on n'est même pas capable de
ça l'europe il est mort ce soir un
garçon ne veut de la licence militaires
non mais non merci bon à ce moment alors
pourquoi faire des communiqués à
l'elysée avec madame merkel et monsieur
macron qu'ils disent est intenable c'est
insupportable sa dette insoutenable
sigean pas les moyens c'est quoi encore
des mots c'est une destruction l'europe
supplémentaire où il disait rien et il
voit là on n'est pas fait pour ça mais
l'union européenne elle devait bien
intervenir au nom de la démocratie et
des valeurs européennes sur justement un
terrain qui est proche d'elle et là il
ya une démission qui est absolument
scandaleuse pour l'opinion parce qu'on a
promis à la turquie pendant des années
de la derrière l'européen et il faut pas
oublier qu'il ya une culture qui avant
et erdogan s'est pas seulement on
l'inscrit la turquie a fait beaucoup de
choses pour essayer d'être exactement
effet beaucoup de choses m'ont que
l'effort était bon prix d'efforts
beaucoup des forces démocratiques c'est
un pays c'est un pays où les militaires
sont intervenus mais sont impartis ils
ont laissé la démocratie en place d'un
pays qui étaient laïques qui ne s'était
pas les pays d'erdogan quand j'analyse
et c'est pas c'est pas assez aussi la
faute de l'europe ne sera abandonné la
tour je me suis que nous expliquer que
monsieur erdogan ce qui était avait des
doutes sur lui quand il a été élu était
un islamiste modéré qu'il fallait pas se
méfier au contraire qu'il allait
faciliter les rapports entre l'europe on
voit la facture aujourd'hui le seul
mensonge et de cette illusion dans cette
période de grande tension il ya un
événement peut-être anecdotique mais en
tout cas avec une symbolique forte c'est
un match de football qui doit avoir lieu
ce soir en france entre l'équipe
nationale française et l'équipe turque
il faut savoir que quand les turcs
jouent au football
ils sont dans une démarche très
patriotique il salue le drapeau il peut
aussi avoir des tensions de sécurité ce
soir certains comme eric ciotti demande
la suspension de ce match le député les
républicains des alpes maritimes était
ce matin sur lci ce match je le dis ne
peut pas avoir lieu dans ces conditions
où autour d'eux
dans un contexte de menaces d'inquiétude
de provocation il faut suspendre en tout
cas il faut pas qu'ils aient lieu ce
soir
moi je demande solennellement pour des
raisons de sécurité d'annuler ce match
ce match peut porter en lui des dangers
des menaces en matière de sécurité
donc ce soir le match ne peut pas avoir
lieu pour des interviews 4 complications
de sécurité sabric vous suivez ces
affaires de sport de société pour la
pour la fondation jean jaurès quel est
votre point de vue si vous en aviez le
pouvoir vous suspendre y y et vous
interdire y ait ce match je pense qu'en
fait on va y être obligés d'annoncer
faut regretter un match de foot n'a pas
être instrumentalisée par une décision
politique mais en l'occurrence le match
est instrumentalisé il est
instrumentalisé d'abord par erdogan est
d'abord par la turquie est aujourd'hui
il faut quand même qu'on le regarde en
face ce scénario il dit quoi il dit
qu'en fait ce match a une résonance qui
n'est plus une résonance portiques et
une résonance qui est quasi politique
géopolitique voire militaire elle pose
effectivement je suis pour une fois
d'accord avec eric ciotti un problème de
de maintien de l'ordre est simplement
d'ordre public comment et comment va se
dérouler ce match s'il doit se dérouler
on sait bien par contre que après la
discussion convient avoir d'avoir c'est
pas le match de foot qui doit être le
soin palliatif de l'ensemble des
impuissances des puissances occidentales
qui à un moment donné cumulées elles
n'ont pas réussi à faire reculer les
reculs et la turquie c'est pas un match
de foot qui a été remis par contre ce
match de foot il est signifiant parce
qu'il est instrumentalisé et en ce sens
je pense qu'à un moment donné il faut
envisager de l'arrêter il faut envisager
le report mais encore une fois c'est pas
parce qu on fera ça qu'on aura gommé et
les impuissances et les lâchetés et les
abandons qui sont à côté c'est en plus
mais ça doit pas être le substitut à un
moment donné de tout ça ça me fait un
peu peur quand j'entends des réactions
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on a plus
d'idées pour arrêter le match qu'on a
plus d'enthousiasmé pour arriver le
match que pourra les arrêter la turquie
et ses troupes et avec celles qui sont
coalisés avec elle sur le terrain en
syrie donc attention à pas jouer un
exercice de com qui est très dangereux
et très glissante donc c'est pas le plus
facile c'est pas le bon terrain mais
concrètement qui peut décider parce
qu'il reste plus beaucoup de temps qui
peut décider de
écoutez la préfecture pourrait très bien
dire que les risques qui sont encourues
par un trouble à l'ordre public qui par
ailleurs n'est pas complètement vin est
fou vous avez vous même rappeler que les
matchs de foot dans les enceintes en
turquie étaient souvent très animée et
très vibrante parfois même très plus que
vibrante et quasi militaire à certains
moments oui on va dire que c'est un
match qui se présente quand même avec
des des relents de tensions possibles
autour du stade de france
on a arrêté pour moins que ça les
interdictions de déplacement de
supporters les interdictions de stades
existent pour beaucoup beaucoup moins de
trouve le possible à l'ordre public et
pour des motivations parfois des
préfectures qui laisse perplexe donc là
on aurait presque un bon argument vrai
et tangibles et dernière question là
dessus on peut techniquement organiser
un match à huis clos ccpo c'est possible
pour pas qu'ils aient de danger avec les
spectateurs
ouais il faut voir quelle est quel est
l'intérêt d'un match d'un match à huis
clos bien sûr on peut le faire mais si
près si près du début je ne sais pas si
le match à huit clos serait une solution
que ça à dire on joue à huis clos mais à
les gens qui sont normalement qui
veulent venir qu'ils aiment et on a deux
d'or à l'extérieur finalement des
problèmes qu'on aura peut-être plus de
mal à régler que si les gens étaient
rentrés l'intérieur du stade et dans
lequel on peut mieux organiser une
sécurité mais je serai prudent on change
de sujet on va parler maintenant des
républicains après le départ de laurent
wauquiez la démission de laurent
wauquiez ce mouvement n'avait plus de
patron c'est désormais le cas avec
l'élection hier au premier tour avec 62%
des voix de christian jacob s'était les
militants
des républicains un jour de cotisation
qui pouvait voter
alors est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les républicains d'avoir à
nouveau un patron on sait que ce parti
traverse une passe difficile
alors pourquoi ce que la droite va pas
bien peut-être parce que elle est déjà
au pouvoir avec emmanuel macron c'est
pas exactement la vie de christian jacob
il l'a redit ce matin sur france inter
le peuple de droite il existe en france
et il n'est pas il n'est pas représenté
aujourd'hui par par emmanuel macron et
par le par la république en marche
il suffit de regarder d'abord
l'incapacité qu'il y a eu à apporter des
réformes économiques si on prend tous
les engagements qui étaient ceux d'
emmanuel macron de baisser la dépense
publique il augmentait davantage que ne
le faisait françois hollande de baisser
la dette
elle n'a cessé d'augmenter depuis qu'il
est au pouvoir alors qu'elles diminuent
dans les pays dans les pays voisins
n'ont pas de réforme de deux structures
là la droite n'est pas incarne
aujourd'hui c'est notre responsablité
nicolas lecaussin il est audible à
christian jacob
j'ai une telle expérience avec les gens
de la droite depuis des années que je
travaille quand les instituts que je me
méfie toi et j'attends j'attends
j'attends voir les actes ce qui faisait
pas mieux vous l'avez matière de gestion
les paroles suis d'accord oui bien sûr
y'a pas de structure ya pas de baisse de
dépenses a pas de baisse du nombre de
fonctionnaires ça oui bien sûr ça il a
raison mais j'attends voir ce qu'il va
faire
christian jacob s'est ain
un ancien si je peux dire ainsi ça fait
longtemps qu'on connaît il s'éteint une
tête nouvelle c'est quelqu'un qui il a
fait partie il était syndicaliste jeunes
agriculteurs il
je ne m'attire pas beaucoup de confiance
pour ce qui est des réformes libérales
affaire que nous demandons que nous
souhaitons à l'iref le paradoxe périco
légasse et qu'il a aussi été élu parce
qu'il a dit moi je me présenterais
jamais à l'élection présidentielle alors
même que peut-être que la droite manque
d'un chef
en général on prend la tête du parti
pour avoir la magistrature suprême
c'était la règle jusqu'à présent mois